but first the government set a target to
offer a first vaccine to all over 70s
nhs and care workers
and care home residents by tomorrow so
will they meet that target well let's
ask a man who should hopefully know the
foreign secretary
dominic graham thank you for being on
the program this morning good morning
so the government's target is to
vaccinate the top four priority groups
by
tomorrow are you going to meet the
target
well there's been huge progress made and
we're confident we're on track to do so
we'll obviously get the final data
um later on today and tomorrow and it
will be a really important milestone
because
that's the top four priority groups that
have been offered the first
dose and it is the if you like the first
milestone
towards the wider plan to get 99
of those at risk of dying vaccinated
with the first dose
um by the end of april and then everyone
in the country
uh every adult in the country offered a
first dose by at the autumn
and that's part of the road maps so uh
the nhs teams i was down at my local
vaccination center in walton
the volunteers there uh nadine zaharawi
matt hancock had done a great job
but of course this is only the first
step
in the vaccination rollout it's going
well but we've got to keep it up
you must know if you're going to meet
the target by tomorrow are you just
leaving it for your boss to announce
well i'm confident we're on track to do
so uh they the
the numbers look good but i want to wait
until we've got the
formally published uh figures so that
we're doing it accurately and
and in the right way so i can't quite
jump the gun
uh but i can tell you that we're on
track and we're confident that we will
meet that target and of course the
target was uh come
come monday so come tomorrow so uh
you'll get the full
um data then but it's a really important
first step uh in the vaccine rollout
and we then evaluate all of the data and
the prime minister on the 22nd of
february so monday we will set out the
plans going forward
because of course we understand people
want to know a bit more uh what the next
stage will involve they want that light
at the end of the tunnel
and it's right that we do it this way
based on the evidence and so far the
evidence is
is positive pretty clear that you're
confident the vaccine rollout is going
well
so far now on friday the prime minister
is going to be hosting this virtual
g7 meeting he's going to call for
further international cooperation on
vaccine distribution
saying that governments have a
responsibility to work together
to put those vaccines to the best
possible use
so does that mean that we are planning
to give
some of our vaccines to other countries
and if so when would we do that at what
point
would we do that and who would we
prioritize
of course we're not going to do anything
that would undermine the integrity of
the domestic rollout that would be
counterproductive
and it's fair to say we have already
contributed on the international track
so these aren't binary choices we've
uh contributed uh over half a billion
pounds that will secure
over a billion doses through what's
called the kovacs
amc facility so we're already just to
jump in sorry you say that you wouldn't
do anything to undermine the domestic
roll out so what does that actually mean
does that mean you're not going to give
any vaccines away until
every adult in the uk receive their
first dose what does that mean
so first of all we are already
supporting and indeed
leading the way with our g7 presidency
of the international
approach we've contributed uh enough
money to reduce
one billion of those doses and what we
want to do is having led the way
encourage and cajole and use our
uh convening power to get other
countries to match that that's the way
we deal with
the global um challenge that we all face
i think the the answer question is would
we
use any surplus uh vaccines from the
450 million doses that we've got for the
domestic rollout
we would need to before we start looking
at that we'll need to know
with confidence that we're able to roll
out
reliably according to the time scales
that we've got
so but these things go in parallel um
we're leading the way i think
domestically with our rollout but also
internationally
and so what the prime minister is doing
is making sure with that
strong example that we're setting we can
also encourage others to make sure
that the vulnerable countries the
poorest countries around the world
are also able to benefit from equitable
distribution of the vaccine
we need a global solution to what is a
global pandemic
okay um now let's talk a bit about the
light of the end of the tunnel that you
mentioned cases are dropping
it seems like you're on course to meet
the targets tomorrow
on vaccines now the government wants to
reopen schools from the 8th of march
what i want to know is are you planning
on reopening
all schools to all pupils at the same
time
or are you considering a staggered
approach where for example primary
schools might go
back first or some pupils in exam year
groups might go back first
yes a good question and i know there'll
be many teachers and parents that want
uh to know those answers which is why
with the approach we've taken we've
always said that on the uh 22nd
of february so monday week the prime
minister will review all the evidence
the impact of the lockdown the impact of
the vaccine
on the transmission rate and the number
of people going into hospitals with
coronavirus
will then set out the forward look but
you're absolutely right on the 8th of
march we are
aiming we are hoping to get schools back
the precise details
we need to just make sure we set out
once we've uh
evaluated all of that evidence so the
prime minister will give more of a steer
on the 22nd but the aim is to get
schools reopening in a responsible way
on the 8th
so is is the answer then you haven't
decided yet whether that's going to be
all schools
or some schools that's dependent on the
data yeah i think we need to wait
to evaluate the data carefully and allow
those plans to be put in place and of
course
the consultation goes into them because
i know that's important for the
stakeholders for the schools
uh and others and then the prime
minister
on monday week will be able to set out
the full detail but because we're making
progress i think we can feel
confident that we will be able to start
that process of getting schools open on
the 8th
and of course there'll be other measures
that the prime minister wants to set out
but it'll be based on the evidence and
the success that we've had
on in terms of rolling out the vaccine
and the impact that has
not just on reducing the number of cases
um but also reducing the pressure on the
nhs
okay now the sunday times and senate
telegraph are both reporting
that at the same time there could be
some
minor relaxation of other rules the
government could announce they say
that adults will be allowed to sit down
outside on a park bench
with one friend so is it really against
the rules right now for you to sit down
on a park bench with one other person is
matt hancock going to be you know
patrolling parks and slapping you with a
10-year jail sentence if he finds you
but you're not going to get a 10-year
jail sentence for a minor mistake on a
park bench but it is absolutely right
until we change the rules we need full
compliance
because that's the way we make the the
progress that i've described
i i can't tell you all the changes that
will be made um because that's the point
of having this review
uh point on the 22nd of february and but
what our priority will be is schools as
a
as i mentioned i think also um it's fair
to say getting
non-essential retail open is going to be
very important and we also
i mean you mentioned things like the
ability to socialize uh
with people outside these things are
quality of life issues they really
matter
and so they're not small things we
understand i appreciate that i'm sure
everyone watching the show does but we
do need to be very careful in how we
proceed we've made good progress
we don't want to see that unravel
because we go too far too quick
as you say you know these aren't small
things there there is a serious point to
the question you know if you're
elderly or you're pregnant going for a
walk your piece of exercise with one
person from another household which is
legal and if you sit down on a park
bench for a moment
is that unlawful are you breaking the
rules
well i think the rules are pretty clear
that the the idea is not to have people
socializing but to follow the very clear
guidance for outdoor
uh activity which is can you sit down on
a park bench to maintain but it all
depends on the context and
in in truth of course the media will
pick up on the old story here and there
but the police have done an incredible
job in applying
rigor but also some common sense so no
one wants to pick up people that
inadvertently find themselves for a
split second in the wrong place but we
do want to make sure people aren't
flouting the rules
that is how we get back control of the
virus that's what we
have the data shows that we're achieving
we don't want to see
um that unraveling so it so it isn't it
it is important but i think we can trust
the police
uh in their interactions with the public
to get that balance right overwhelmingly
they have
uh over the course of this pandemic okay
now a group of your conservative
colleagues
have written to the prime minister they
say there's no justification for any
restrictions to remain beyond the end of
april because by then all nine priority
groups should have been given a vaccine
dose
and those groups of course represent 99
percent of covert deaths around 80
percent of hospitalizations
are they wrong well that's our a that's
the roadmap to get 99
of those who are at risk of dying from
this
the road map to ease all restrictions by
the end of april
that's not the plan though is it no
you're you're i'm putting words in my
mouth
the plan is to get the 99 of people at
risk of dying
dispense their first dose by the end of
april certainly offered their first dose
and by doing so and taking the fatality
out of this
uh virus we are in a much better
position to proceed to start to ease the
um the lock down and we've just talked
about the way we're going to do it
starting with schools non-sexual
retail i don't think you can set though
an arbitrary target and not be
evidence-led
which is why the review point on the
22nd of february is so important we can
see the success
we've made um and as you rightly point
out
the we we look on course to hit the
first milestone tomorrow
then there is by the end of april to
have a further 70
million people uh offered their first
dose and we want every adult
offer their first dose by september
that's the roadmap we've set out we need
to be evidence-based
in analyzing our progress towards it but
they're saying that if
those people are vaccinated all nine
priority groups
then restrictions should end do you
agree with that or not we're not
taking a uh what what feels to me
slightly arbitrary
uh commitment without reviewing the
impact the measures have
had on the transmission and the hospital
admissions
of the virus so in that sense we're
making sure that as we go and we take
the
the steps both on the vaccine but then
in due course as we open up schools of
course
we want to see what impact that has on
the virus and
and we need to retain some flexibility
to deal with the variants
uh which of course are part and parcel
of dealing with the pandemic but do
alter
the precise time frame so we'll be
evidence-led but we share the
the ambition to get out of a lockdown to
transition to a better place for
economic reasons for jobs for
livelihoods
for the most vulnerable in our society
and for everyone's mental health
and professor neil ferguson this week um
of imperial college told me that some
low level restrictions face mask
wearing could even go into next year do
you think that's realistic
i just don't jump the gun on the series
of
uh measures that the prime minister will
announce and the roadmap
all of these things will be looked at in
the round okay now from tomorrow
uh arrivals from certain countries will
have to go into hotel quarantine
so how many hotels are currently signed
up and how many
rooms was the government booked oh i
don't know
the precise number of rooms booked but
you're right to say
there are 33 countries in the high risk
the red list if you like
particularly from south america and from
africa
and in relation to british nationals
coming home
so you wouldn't be able to if you're a
foreign national coming from those
countries you won't be able to
uh come back there's a bar on uh entry
into the uk but if you're a british
national
or resident trying to get back home we
will have a system of uh
government commissioned uh uh hotel
based
quarantine for the 10 days subject to
tests and a lot of preparations gone
into that
to make sure and it's only one
additional measure if you like one extra
safeguarding the lines of defense that
we've got against new variants coming in
but i do think it's significant and
important
on top of the other border-based
restrictions we've now put in place
the times reported yesterday that so far
only 16
hotels have signed up none of them north
of birmingham and that we could run out
of rooms by thursday because there's
only 5 000 booked
and we're expecting 1 400 arrival today
so
i understand you're probably not across
the detail of exactly how many rooms but
are we going to have enough
i think we will and of course i mean the
truth is the the travel is
largely uh dried up in any event but
what this measure allows is
one thousand four hundred arrivals a day
is quite a lot still isn't it
nowhere near complete comparison to the
kind of travel i mean
uh when if you look at heathrow um
airport or any of our airports
uh that they're they're empty compared
to what we've seen previously but we do
need to make
sure we've got is a safe reliable
workable system for
uk nationals from those uh 33 high
risk countries so that we don't find
unwittingly uh or otherwise that the
progress made
in terms of the vaccine and control of
the virus is undermined and those plans
are now being properly implemented uh
we've taken our time to get them right
and they'll be
we'll be able to deliver them from
monday you talked about 33 countries
being
on the red list but of course there are
other countries where the south africa
variant the variant of concern
has been found austria for example the
austrian region of tyrell went to
lockdown on tuesday after 293 cases at
the south africa variant were concerned
austria is not on the list isn't it not
time to have a blanket ban
i'm not sure that's proportionate and of
course
having blanket bans on any for example
air travel into the uk would be very
difficult for the supply chains
things like freight which sometimes come
in you can exempt
freight you can accept freight can't you
that's what france has done
well you look there are different ways
of looking at we assess
the data very carefully so whenever uh
there is an outbreak or a deterioration
in one another country look at it very
carefully
um and we what we want to make sure is
we've got as targeted measure as
possible
to keep those supply chains open to make
sure british nationals or residents can
come back from abroad
but also to avoid undermining the
progress we've made
and we think we've got the right balance
robust measures but targeted measures
okay do we know how many cases of the
south africa variant there are currently
in the uk
i don't have that data i'm not sure it's
ascertainable and of course
people refer to it as the south african
variant
actually the south africans have a bit
more advanced in many other countries in
the genomic testing
so the question is where the variant
first uh is
trapped um and we've of course had a
similar issue we
we're world leaders in genomic testing
and we're very transparent about things
um so uh like the south african so the
truth is these variants as in the course
of any
pandemic and any virus happen um and
the point is that we've got the measures
in place the tracking
the expertise in genomic sequencing and
the international collaboration the
cooperation you have with countries
around the world to make sure we can
track it very carefully
and take proportionate measures now i
just want to finish by asking you about
ann
sekulos the american woman involved in
the 2019
crash that killed the teenager harry
dunn now she claimed diplomatic
community returned to the u.s they've
since
refused to extradite her now ten days
ago her bastard told a u.s court that
she was employed by an intelligence
agency in the u.s at the time of the
crash
which was especially a factor in her
departure from the uk
now this matters because if she was
employed herself she wouldn't have had
diplomatic immunity so when did you or
the prime minister first become aware
that antaculis was employed by an
intelligence agency
at the time of the crash yeah well look
first of all we don't um comment on
intelligence matters but what i can tell
you
categorically because it's not quite
right what you've said is at the time
that ann sekules was in the uk and the
basis
of her immunity was as the uh
partner of an officer at the embassy um
and and that was the the basis for it
um and we obviously sought wave of
immunity um
and we've sought her return under
extradition
and we continue to do so and of course
i've raised it with the new
u.s secretary of state um we want to see
justice for
the family of harry dan and we do
believe that dan secular should return
did the u.s not tell you that she was
employed
by the u.s intelligence agencies at the
time of the crash as her lawyer
has said well sophie as i said first of
all we don't comment on intelligence
matters but what i can say categorically
is that her status was uh as the partner
the spouse
of an officer of the embassy and that
was the way both the us with us and uh
approach things in the way we did
and the other speculation had no impact
and wouldn't have had
any uh any uh effect on the status that
she had in the uk
so you know it now we all know it now
because it's been widely reported
when did you first find out that she was
employed by the u.s intelligence
services
so sophie you can ask me the questions
many times you like i don't comment
and uh pass comment on intelligence
matters at all
but what i can say categorically when
we've been clear with the
the family as well about this is that
her status was very clear and it was
based
on her being the the wife of an officer
of the embassy up at crouton so that was
the basis on which
she had immunity we of course wanted it
waived we of course wanted
her to be returned after she left and
that remains our position
so can you guarantee that you didn't
know that she was employed by an
intelligence agency before
she left for the u.s so i can guarantee
that i don't comment on intelligence
matters
as many times to ask me okay dominic rob
thank you for coming on the program
today much appreciated
good to talk to you